oh right that is it you cannot blow up
my head with your mind trying to blow up
my head but you so it was working see
about that
do two heads up you people in the proper
Oh this is a splash zone I really loved
what they had done the moment I read the
pilot and I really really wanted to get
the chance to play that character that
was on there and and I was just really
happy that I have gotten said they have
that chance to do it and we are till
you'll see my non-working watch which
I've had since the pilot it's never
worked and it says 126 and I will check
it every time I have it on at some point
like a fool no no not as smart as
Sheldon that was Jim Parsons on the set
of The Big Bang Theory in 2007 dishing
on his character Sheldon this is
hopefully a very humorous peek into the
lives of honest-to-god geniuses and the
problems and hilarity that that causes
in their lives and dealing with general
public I think more than anything it's
about getting a peek into to these
really smart people and how they operate
I have any chopsticks
you don't need chopsticks this is Thai
food here we go Thailand has had two
forks since the latter half of the 19th
century I think that everyone has their
own nerd that they can identify ways
when they see this and you know a lot of
times though it's fun to say walked in
action flick say or whatever that could
be a little bit hard to identify with
then being awkward or being you know in
out of place in the social situation are
you listening to yourself
it is well established Superman's flight
is a feat of strength it is an extension
of his ability to leap tall buildings an
ability he derives from exposure to
Earth's Yellow Sun I'm just gonna go
wash up
mrs. Sheldon and Sheldon that would be
me has a love of the comic books
I'm a medium as you can see Superman
undies and all prepping to play a
brainiac was no easy task
my honest-to-god went out to the
bookstore and bought a physics
dictionary obviously a regular regular
dictionary this is the first time in my
life if anybody asked me how'd you
memorize all those lines I would
actually sit down and tell them you have
completely skipped over that moment rod
was walking in the park and I saw those
children on the merry-go-round which
started me thinking about the moment of
inertia and gases like helium and
temperatures approaching absolute zero
I didn't skip it it's just an anecdote
it's not science oh I see it was the
Apple falling on Newton's head just an
anecdote you are not Isaac Newton but
that's true gravity would have been
apparent to me without the Apple you
cannot possibly be that arrogant and
continue to underestimate me my good man
and you have a blessed friend over at
UCLA who actually took Johnny and I on a
tour of the physics department and we
saw everything up and down that place
and some materials they're working with
that was a little bit mind-blowing and
we literally talked about things like
the possible elevator to space and we're
pretty are you joking no okay I should
leave Nick memorize my lines
[Applause]
you